[Music]  las vegas city councilwoman michelle  fiore says she wants to be nevada's next  governor she made the announcement today  with this video where she's wearing a  red dress and a handgun in the desert  and shooting beer bottles with labels  like socialism she joins a crowded  republican field and says she won't  compromise  right now  we have republican elected officials  across the country congratulating  themselves working with pelosi and the  biden administration  that isn't me  you'll never hear me do that  fiori did not take any questions her  campaign consultant says she'll likely  be available for interviews sometime  later this week  fiore joining a pretty crowded  republican primary field which includes  early front-runners clark county sheriff  joe lombardo former senator dean heller  las vegas north las vegas mayor john lee  venture capitalist ghee nora and reno  attorney joey gilbert